there is a new poll about the virus
which shows that republicans democrats
and independents
are really living in alternate moral
realities when it comes to coronavirus
deaths now notice that i'm not saying
alternate realities
in this case everybody was presented
with the fact
that at the time 176 000 people had died
of coronavirus the poll was done a few
days ago
we're now close to 181 000 coronavirus
deaths but at the time
republicans democrats and independents
were told 176 000 people have died of
coronavirus okay
presented with that fact do you believe
that is an acceptable amount of death
most republicans believe it is of course
democrats and independents don't think
176 000 deaths is acceptable so this is
a cbs
news yougov poll of 2200 registered
voters
margin of error of 2.4 and it found that
57 percent of republicans believe
176 000 coronavirus deaths is acceptable
more than half of republicans
believe that's an acceptable death toll
only 10 percent of democrats
believe 176 000 deaths is acceptable
and only 33 percent of independents do
by a two-to-one margin independents
believe the death toll is
unacceptable now first of all it's the
hypocrisy
a ton of these same republicans who say
176
000 coronavirus deaths are acceptable
thought barack obama
needed to resign because two people died
of ebola in the united states
there's always a hypocrisy angle let's
not make that the focus today
secondly there's a morality component
here
is it possible that the reason
republicans think the deaths are
acceptable
is that early on the deaths were mostly
in blue states
with direct aviation links to
china and the other countries in europe
that were seated with the virus early
could it be that republicans are okay
with deaths
as long as they're mostly democratic
voters i don't know the answer to that
but it's certainly possible but the
really interesting thing statistically
is that you don't have an even partisan
divide and that could be a factor
in november and i want to be really
clear about explaining this
we always expect uh that all else being
equal
if you have a purely partisan divide in
any issue
you would expect for example that
independence would be roughly 50 50
split
on an issue and you would expect that
the democrat republican
uh imbalance would be equal this isn't
super clear the way i'm explaining it so
so let me give you an example
you would expect that if republicans
support
something 70 30 democrats
would oppose it 70 30 all else being
equal meaning if there isn't some other
factor to consider now there's always
some other factor to consider right so
when you look at abortion
you don't have approval for abortion in
most cases among democrats
equal to disapproval among republicans
there's religious components
there's other factors that go into it so
right now the country is
more in favor of abortion than they've
ever been and part of it is you don't
have an even partisan divide yes
republicans are more against abortion
than democrats
but it's not to the same degree okay
here with this question on the
acceptability of coronavirus deaths
the partisan divide is very unequal if
we look at the numbers again you'll see
that
even among republicans 43 percent think
the death toll is unacceptable
it is unbalanced with the democratic
number
showing us that this issue is stronger
than partisanship
it's still hugely partisan but even
republicans 43 percent of them are
putting aside partisanship and saying
the death toll is not acceptable despite
it being
our guy trump who oversaw it it's not
acceptable and then of course when you
look at
independents who are not 50 50 split
but by a two to one margin say this is
not okay
this could be a difference maker in
november coronavirus is polling as a top
issue for voting in november and even
among republicans 43 percent say the
results are unacceptable
if some of those republicans vote biden
if
some of them say i'm not going to vote
biden but i'm going to stay home
it could be enough to push trump out of
office now of course on the other side
we've got voter suppression
the postal service foreign meddling all
of this stuff so
that's why we need to bring out enforce
these folks who already democrats by a
90 to 10 margin
think the coronavirus handling is
unacceptable
we've got to make sure that they vote
last thing
how can republicans call themselves
pro-life and be the group that by the
largest margin
believes 176 000 deaths are acceptable
just something to think about today one
of our sponsors is
surf shark which is the vpn that i use
to protect my privacy anytime i'm on the
internet they're giving my audience
85 off a two-year plan that's under two
bucks a month
plus you'll get three extra months for
free it's 20 20. it's time for you to
start using a vpn if you're not already
protect yourself
against government surveillance against
internet service providers selling your
internet history
against tech companies spying on you
online surf shark is the vpn i trust
because unlike
other vpns they don't monitor or log
your activity
it encrypts all your data you can
install it on unlimited devices it'll
block ads it'll protect you from malware
and phishing
there are a ton of other special
features that come with it go check it
out
surf shark is giving my audience 85 off
a two-year plan which comes out to
less than two bucks a month plus you'll
get three extra months for
free go to surfshark.deals
pacman the link is right underneath this
video